[Music]
don't you wish you were there as
americans debate covet vaccine and mass
mandates italy has introduced some of
the strictest protocols in the world to
prevent the virus from spreading more
than 76 percent of the italian
population is fully vaccinated but the
country is still reporting hundreds of
daily deaths since the omicron variant
hit the nation the government is taking
a very aggressive somewhat say
controversial approach to keeping people
safe chris livesay traveled to venice to
check out the restrictions and to find
out how some italians feel about them
good morning italy has some of the
toughest covid restrictions in the world
in most cases only the fully vaccinated
are allowed to board public
transportation the unvaccinated are
still free to walk unless of course
surrounded by water
in dante's inferno it was the damned who
were ferried across the river styx for
their sins today in covidera venice it's
the unvaccinated who depend on boatmen
like michele savolnano i call it like a
charity
offer i don't i don't ask for money for
this an estimated 5 thousand venetians
aren't vaccinated meaning that with few
exceptions water buses are off limits we
can't escape you know from our island
it's the only way to reach your job or
to reach your school
so they got organized and now those with
boats help out the rest where are you
going to survive and go to my job
it's an underground network savoriano
likens to early christians hiding in the
catacombs when you are a minority
it's
people
are afraid for their jobs for their
families to be clear the unvaccinated
can still board fairies to get medical
help or if they're minors going to
school venice city councilman marco
gasparinetti says those who choose to
skip the vaccine must be prepared for
the consequences there is a price to pay
you're not vaccinated you will not have
access to certain services i made a
choice of being vaccinated but i do not
agree with all what has been put in
place
to discourage or to make life life
impossible for those who are not in rome
we followed police as they cracked down
on commuters like rose kamau a hotel
housekeeper they said i have to pay 280
euros or something her crime wearing a
surgical mask required for everyone
outdoors instead of an n95 mask now
required aboard all buses they have to
like give you a warning you know
because everybody is confused today we
are we have to follow this rule tomorrow
we are following another rule you know
but they're producing results according
to a recent study the rules have
incentivized nearly 10 percent more
italians to get vaccinated today more
than 80 percent of the population has
received at least one dose some call the
laws draconian others
life-saving
and they're not limited to
transportation if you're not vaccinated
you can't go to the movies you can't go
to a hotel you can't go to restaurants
you pretty much can't have a social life
outside of your house and similar
measures are in place across europe in
france president macron said one of the
reasons for these strict rules and this
is a quote is to piss off the
unvaccinated for cbs morning's chris
livesay venice
well that's that's one tactic that's one
way to look at it but i i'm going to go
along with the life-saving part of it
yeah i also think about that i think
comparing on the mandate to the
christians hiding in the catacombs to
escape deadly persecution
bit over the top yeah and also there's
power in the choice of words saying
you're pissing off the unvaccinated that
also could be pushing away it is pushing
away i agree completely yes that part
isn't helpful yeah